SIERRA: Neighbors. Everyone has them, and
the kind you have can make a big difference
in your life. They can be frustrating or they
can be a godsend, it all depends. Countries
are in the same situation. Good neighbors
can mean beneficial security and trade agreements.
Bad neighbors can mean border crises, conflict
over resources, and even war. Today we are
looking at one of our neighbors - Mexico.
By most measures they re a good neighbor - it
s been a very long time since there was any
military conflict between our two nations,
and Mexico is arguably the United States most
important trade partner. This closeness has
allowed the U.S. to rely on peace in its own
neighborhood, and to focus on other issues
abroad. Still, a lot remains misunderstood
about Mexico in the United States, particularly
when it comes to hot button issues like trade,
immigration and drug trafficking. I'm Gabrielle
Sierra, and this is Why It Matters. Today,
Mexico.
Montage: Mexico, Mexico, Mexico, Mexico, Mexico,
Mexico, Mexico, Mexico
SIERRA: So let's do a little Mexico 101. If
I know nothing about Mexico, what are some
things that I should know?
O'NEIL: So Mexico is our Southern neighbor.
We share a 2,000 mile border with the country.
It's a country of about 120 million people.
It is a democracy though recently has been
struggling as such.
SIERRA: This is Shannon O'Neil, she s a senior
fellow for Latin America studies at the Council
on Foreign Relations.
O'NEIL: When you look around the world, there's
probably no country that affects more what
happens day to day in the United States than
Mexico. So the vegetables and fruits that
are on your table that you eat every morning
or every evening, the appliances that you
buy, the other goods that you purchase that
you fill your houses with, the communities
in which you live and the restaurants that
are down the street perhaps and the broader
culture, all of those things as well as today
some 11 million Mexicans and 35 million Mexican
Americans who are a big part of the US population.
So the communities that so many of us exist
in and around too, are also tied to Mexico.
It is our most important trading partner,
ahead of Canada and ahead of China. It is
important in terms of our shared environment
along the border, in terms of our industries
as well as our waterways. And it is important
in terms of security, in terms of border security,
but in terms of security overall and the joint
fight against organized crime.
SIERRA: Each of the connections Shannon just
mentioned are at times headline issues in
the United States. But among them, the economic
relationship may be the most important, and
least understood. In 2019, more than $677
billion dollars in trade was conducted between
Mexico and the United States, affecting 5
million jobs. Again, that s higher than overall
trade with China in the same year. And underneath
the big numbers, the ties go deeper.
O'NEIL: And so today interestingly, when you
look at products in the United States, Mexico
and Canada are integral to the making of those
products and these countries are big buyers
of US goods and services when they make products.
So for instance, a product that comes in from
Mexico, so it was imported into the United
States from Mexico, on average, about 40%
of that product was actually made in the United
States. So US workers put things together
that are then sent to Mexico to be assembled.
If you look at products coming in from China,
it's less than 4% that was made in the United
States. So pretty much everything is made
on the other side of the ocean. So Mexico
and the United States are incredibly important
to each other because they make things together.
SIERRA: But this level of cooperation hasn
t always been the case. And it s not something
that should be taken for granted.
O'NEIL: So Mexico, if you look back in the
1980s, it was really a country that sold commodities
north to the United States, primarily oil
and some agricultural products, and it was
a quite closed economy. So it had a lot of
tariffs and other kinds of barriers that kept
the US from selling goods to the south. The
big shift really happened in the early 1990s
with the formation and signing of NAFTA, the
North American Free Trade Agreement that brought
Mexico, the United States, and Canada together
in a free trade region. And you see in the
wake of NAFTA over the next decade, trade
grow exponentially between the countries,
and over these last 25, 30 years, the nature
of that trade, not only has it grown fourfold,
but it has also changed. So it's gone from
commodities, from selling oil, from selling
fruits and vegetables and like which still
are sold, but to advanced manufacturing products.
So auto parts and medical devices and airplanes
and all kinds of other types of equipment
and higher tech goods are now sold between
all of these countries.
SIERRA: How did life in Mexico change for
people after the country embraced free trade?
And what has that meant for the United States?
CAMPERO: I mean, let me just give you an anecdote.
SIERRA: This is Mariana Campero, she s an
expert in the Americas program at CSIS. She
is also the host of the Mexico Matters podcast.
And former CEO of the Mexican Council on Foreign
Relations, COMEXI.
CAMPERO: When I was a little girl, I remember
my trips to the United States as one of the
most incredible things in the world, because
I was able to buy US candy. My mother bought
US toothpaste and shampoos. It sounds trivial,
but in Mexico, we did not have, in our shelves,
US products, or very little of them. And those
that existed in Mexico were very expensive.
So one of the things that NAFTA, when it came
into effect, it radically changed the life
of Mexican consumers, because suddenly we
were able to have every product from every
part of the world, and with the best quality
at cheaper prices. Sort of more importantly,
because of NAFTA, Mexico, especially the Northern
part of Mexico which was closer to the United
States, and so therefore transport costs were
lower, was able to develop, and it became
a true manufacturing powerhouse. The Mexican
economy was able to grow its Northern parts
at rates that were close to Asian countries.
Some parts of the Northern grew at 10%. That
also allowed for a lot of the people in the
south to move north to work in these maquiladoras
or manufacturing facilities.
SIERRA: NAFTA eliminated taxes on imported
and exported goods, as long as they met certain
manufacturing requirements, allowing products,
parts, and services to be traded essentially
for free. As a result, prices went down, and
choices became more abundant. This benefited
businesses, shareholders, and consumers, and
many economists would say that on net NAFTA
was a good thing. But not everyone shares
this opinion. NAFTA was controversial from
the moment it was signed, and over the years,
many politicians, and many workers, have blamed
NAFTA for US job losses.
Bill CLINTON: In a few moments I will sign
the North American Free Trade Act into law,
NAFTA will tear down trade barriers between
our three nations.
Ross PEROT: When you ve not a 7:1 wage differential
between the U.S. and Mexico you will hear
the giant sucking sound.
Donald TRUMP: NAFTA is the worst trade deal
maybe ever signed anywhere, but certainly
ever signed in this country.
Bernie SANDERS: Corporate America and the
big money interests have told us that NAFTA
is a good deal, I don t believe them.
SIERRA: So in some political circles, I feel
like NAFTA was also seen as something that
cost American jobs. Is that the case?
O'NEIL: Well, it's interesting. When you look
at the decade after NAFTA was signed, sort
of the 1990s, jobs in all three countries
increased and the sales between all three
countries increased. And in fact, Mexico was
one of the biggest consumer markets for US
goods. Around 2001, that starts to change.
And one of the big changes is that China comes
into the WTO and you see more and more goods
coming from China to the rest of the world.
So that, you know, we talk about here in the
United States, the China shock and the effect
that China had on US goods and sales and US
jobs. Well, they'd had a similar effect and
perhaps even a bigger effect on jobs in Mexico.
So whole industries that were based in Mexico,
textiles and toy making and shoe making, so
much of that disappeared. And as it disappeared,
so did US-based suppliers that used to sell
the leather for shoes or the high heels or
the sorts of things down there. So you see
this symbiotic relationship. So that first
decade when China really wasn't part of the
picture, you saw jobs increase throughout
the three countries. Over the 2000s and into
the 2010s, you saw jobs fall in all three
countries, but in part because of challenges
and competition from other parts of the world.
SIERRA: So is NAFTA still in place?
O'NEIL: So NAFTA was in place until just about
a year plus ago when it was replaced with
the USMCA, the US, Mexico, and Canada Agreement.
So this is basically a NAFTA update. It kept
some of the things in the initial agreement.
It added things that hadn't really been thought
about in 1992, in 1993 when the initial agreement
was negotiated. So things like the internet
and e-commerce, digital trade and the like,
digital information and how you store it,
or the privacy rights. So all of those are
new, bigger aspects of the USMCA that weren't
all there in the original NAFTA.
SIERRA: All right, so I have to train myself
to use a new acronym.
O'NEIL: I know. All the time.
SIERRA: All the time.
SIERRA: There s a reason that NAFTA, and the
USMCA, have gotten so much attention in the
news and in election cycles. Jobs mean a lot
to voters. And because feelings about them
run so deep, politicians on both sides of
the aisle have often taken up these trade
agreements as campaign issues. It s a clear
example of how our relationship with Mexico
shows up at the center of national debates.
There s another big issue that shows up in
the same way, one that is often just as misunderstood.
Immigration. This year, the number of undocumented
migrants at the southern border hit the highest
level in over 20 years. Migrants came from
around the world as Covid and its economic
consequences drove ever higher numbers of
people from their homes.
SIERRA: Let's turn to the issue that we hear
about most often, especially over these past
politically tense years here in the US, immigration.
So what have some of the most important inflection
points been as this issue has played out over
the years?
O'NEIL: So for many years, Mexico was the
biggest source of migrants to the United States.
And you saw an uptick start in 1970s and 1980s,
continue in the 1990s and hit a real high
in the early 2000s where Mexicans were coming
to the United States for a whole host of reasons.
There had been economic booms and busts that
drove people north. There was a demographic
boom. So lots of Mexicans were turning 16,
17, 18 every year and didn't really have anywhere
to go in terms of their own labor market.
And you also saw throughout the 1990s, Mexico
struggling to democratize, to move from an
authoritarian system to a democratic system
and many people and families were pushed out
by the authoritarian government before that.
So there's lots of reasons that were pushing
Mexicans to come to the United States. You
have seen over the last 10 to almost 15 years
a decline in Mexican migration to the United
States. And here again, there are lots of
reasons. So part of it is the economy has
been doing better there. You haven't seen
the wild swings in the past that would lead
people to search for opportunities in different
places. You've seen a more stable political
system and a democracy. So many people feel
their voices are heard now when they had not
been in the past. And crucially, you also
see changing numbers of people who turn 15,
16, 17 every year and are trying to enter
into the labor market. So compared to 2000,
they're anywhere between 100,000 and 200,000
fewer people turning 18 every year that are
even looking for a job. So there's more space
in the labor market in Mexico than in the
past.
CAMPERO: In the last few years, you know,
just before the pandemic and before this administration,
Mexican migration to the U.S. was almost net
zero. That means that the flows of people
coming into the United States were more or
less equal to the people coming back to Mexico,
because there were job opportunities that
were created in Mexico on a yearly basis.
SIERRA: That s right Mexico is close to net
zero in terms of immigration to the United
States. Though that fact is often lost in
media coverage and political debate.
Al Jazeera: The U.N. has urged the Trump administration
to immediately stop separating migrant children
from their families at its border with Mexico.
Donald TRUMP: When Mexico sends its people
they re not sending their best.
ABC News: More than 172,00 migrants were stopped
at the border last month, the most in 20 years.
O'NEIL: So the migration today that we're
talking a lot about in the United States and
have been for the last number of years is
not about Mexican migration as much, but it's
about migration from other places that comes
through Mexico. So since 2014, 2015, we have
seen waves of Central Americans coming up
through Mexico to come to the United States.
And we've obviously seen it just this last
year in 2021, increases from Central America
driven by violence and poverty and bad governance
and corruption and all sorts of factors. Many
Central Americans are leaving and looking
for life elsewhere and many pulled to the
United States.
CAMPERO: The biggest spike that we saw in
the Northern border was migrants from Central
America, particularly from the Northern triangle.
What we're seeing recently is that Mexico
is not only an export country, it became a
transit country, and now it is becoming a
receiving country. So now Mexico also has
its own problem to deal with when the fact
is that a lot of the people that were not
able to stay in the United States or to cross
the border into the United States, want to
stay in Mexico. And they have asked for asylum
in Mexico, and this has put tremendous pressure
into our own communities, into our own governmental
authorities that are trying to cope with thousands
and thousands of people. So Mexico has a huge
problem to deal with and we don't have not
even close to the resources, nor the capabilities,
to really deal with this issue in a humane
or in a professional manner.
O'NEIL: So recently we've seen lots of Haitians,
tens of thousands of Haitians coming, but
we see people coming through Mexico from all
different parts of the world, sometimes as
far as Asia or as Africa, but coming to Mexico
and then coming up to the US border seeking
asylum or seeking to come in through other
or means to try to find their way in the United
States. So Mexico has become a gateway for
migration to the United States. And so there's
two things here. One is that is a tension,
as we've seen in the United States both in
the US trying to regulate the migration that
comes into the United States. The other challenge
is Mexico is absorbing tens of thousands,
indeed more than that, of these migrants into
Mexico. So they get, especially Central Americans
get part way into Mexico and then they end
up staying there as do Haitians as do others.
So this is a nation that is a middle income
country, has its own challenges with poverty
and job creation and the like and they are
absorbing now many migrants as well.
SIERRA: So then are the US and Mexico working
together on immigration?
O'NEIL: The US and Mexico have been working
together on immigration largely over the last
few years to close or limit the movement of
people into the United States across the US-Mexico
border. We have seen over the last nine or
10 months under the Biden administration,
some changes in those rules and the setting
up and expanding of the immigration system
at the border to process people in quicker
and more comprehensive ways. So you're starting
to see more families particularly and mothers
and others with kids come through and be processed
and brought into the United States. So there
is cooperation on managing the system at the
border. But I will say this has been one of
the most difficult parts of the relationship
because it is hard to do, to know what to
do, and to build capacity to manage tens of
thousands, hundreds of thousands of people
that are flowing through. And one of the bigger
challenges too is that Mexico just doesn't
have the capacity to do that.
SIERRA: How we build this capacity is an ongoing
political debate. Many ideas have been floated,
like increasing funds for child welfare professionals,
translators, and medical staff at border facilities,
and initiating community housing programs
to limit the use of detention centers. Many
of these ideas might be effective, but big
change is a hard sell on both sides of the
border. One important step is recognizing
that it s a shared problem. The migrants seeking
asylum have escaped prosecution and violence
in their home countries, and in order to get
to the U.S., they need to cross through Mexico.
As a result, Mexico has had to shoulder significant
burdens of its own due to the migrant crisis,
and is scrambling to find a solution, just
as the U.S. is. Misunderstanding about shared
problems emerges as a theme over and over
again in US-Mexico relations. And that is
certainly the case when it comes to another
issue that has persisted for decades: drug-trafficking
and gang violence.
Al Jazeera: More than 300,000 people have
been killed in Mexico since the start of the
US-led war on drugs in 2006. And today, Mexico
continues to make headlines as one of the
most dangerous countries in Latin America.
CBS Mornings: Officials along the southern
border say Mexican drug cartels are moving
much larger shipments of drugs into the US.
The amount of fentanyl, an especially dangerous
substance, that was confiscated by the Texas
Department of Public Safety jumped 800% in
just one year.
O'NEIL: Security is a huge issue in the US-Mexico
relations and it goes both ways. Mexico has
since the late '80s through the '90s become
one of the biggest sources of drugs that are
imported into the United States, starting
with marijuana and cocaine, and then moving
into 2010s to meth, and then today, much of
the fentanyl that comes into the United States,
it's from abroad comes through Mexico. The
precursors come from China mostly, but they
come through Mexico. So it is a huge source
of illegal drugs that come into the United
States. On the other side, the United States
ships back lots of money that pays for those
drugs, as well as guns that go to Mexico that
many of these cartels and organized crime
buy. So there's a illegal trade happening
in both directions, both of them problematic
and harmful to the two societies on either
side. And what we see, obviously we have huge
costs here in the United States due to illegal
drugs and particularly in recent years, the
rise of fentanyl. We saw 70,000 Americans
die last year from fentanyl and opioid overdoses.
You know, in Mexico, we saw a record high
homicides last year as well and largely tied
to organized crime and just the violence that's
associated with illegal activities, drug trafficking
being one of them, contraband being others,
human trafficking and migrants, as well as
other types of illegal activities, especially
extortion and others on the ground. So insecurity
on both sides of the border feed into each
other and make both countries less safe.
SIERRA: It s a tragic feedback loop, and the
United States contributes to it in complicated
ways. For example, it s estimated that half
a million guns are smuggled from the U.S.
to Mexico each year. The problem is so severe
that the Mexican government has filed a lawsuit
against several US gun companies, alleging
that they knowingly supply the criminal gun
market.
CAMPERO: The fact that the United States has
not been able or to curb the sale of arms
to the Mexican cartels has become an irritant.
From a Mexican point of view, I don't think
we have fully recognized our own fault and
our lack of rule of law that obviously has
allowed the Mexican cartels to grow and be
all-powerful, and they are even a threat to
the state.
SIERRA: In 2020, there were 34,515 homicides
in Mexico, a per capita rate several times
higher than in the United States. In the most
recent midterm election 89 politicians, including
35 candidates, were killed. And that s not
all, according to Mexico s National Search
Commission, there are 100,000 unresolved cases
of missing people in the country, a problem
that goes back decades.
SIERRA: It's difficult for me to imagine a
reality in which organized crime has so much
power, a world where it might be a relatively
common experience to have a friend or a loved
one disappear and to suspect or know that
it likely involved a cartel.
CAMPERO: Yeah, I agree with you. I think it's
a horrible reality, and in Mexico, it is a
reality that a lot of people have lived. I
mean, you probably remember the case a few
years ago in which a students just disappeared
and they they have not been found. So their
bodies were burned or what happened to their
bodies, it's really unclear yet. There has
not been a full investigation as to what happened
to those students. But it is the reality of
a lot of mothers in Mexico have taken upon
themselves to go out and find their own loved
ones, and they have found mass graves, in
which they have sort of done the work to identify
what are the remains of their own family members.
It is a reality, unfortunately, for a lot
of people in a lot of Mexican communities.
SIERRA: Do we see the US and Mexico cooperating
on security problems?
O'NEIL: The US and Mexico have had moments
of close cooperation on this. And in fact,
in 2007, 2008, we saw a whole new initiative
called the M rida Initiative which was signed
between at the time President Calderone in
Mexico and Bush here in the United States
that really opened up security cooperation
in ways that hadn't been there for many years.
That has in more recent years fallen somewhat
by the wayside. And in fact, the current president,
L pez Obrador, and his foreign minister have
said that it's not working and they want to
renegotiate it all. And you see frustration
in the US Capitol on the Congress as well
as the executive branch in security cooperation
attenuating or sort of dissipating in recent
years. So I think this is a real challenge
for the two countries because it is so tied.
You can't fix the problem in one place without
also addressing it in the other. So the security
cooperation, there have been strong moments
in the bilateral relationship and in the history,
but today isn't one of them.
SIERRA: Trade, migration, drugs and security.
These are complex challenges that hit deep
political nerves in both Mexico and the United
States. And their persistence through the
years raises questions about how leaders on
both sides of the wall are handling the relationship.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit about
Mexico's current president known to the world
as AMLO?
O'NEIL: Yes. So his full name is Andr s Manuel
L pez Obrador, but everybody calls him AMLO
because you couldn't say that every day. He
has been running for president or he had been
running for president for many, many years.
He lost two elections. Then he finally won
on the third time, which was in 2018. He is
seen as outside of the normal political elites.
He talks with a bit of a different accent.
He speaks much more slowly than people from
Mexico City, and he positions himself as being
outside of those circles of fancy people or
what he calls them fifis. So sort of those
who are elite and have traveled and speak
English and do other kinds of things. He sees
that as not his base. That he is tied to the
more average Mexican and the issues that they
deal with. So he paints himself really as
a populist, as an outsider, and came in with
a really sweeping majority So that was the
wave that brought him into power a few years
ago.
SIERRA: Seems like there's a but coming here.
O'NEIL: There is a but coming. And so while
he came in and he said he was going to tackle
crime and he was going to tackle corruption,
which were the two things Mexicans most wanted
change on, he has not. And in fact, he if
anything is going in the opposite direction.
So under his watch, we have seen homicides
and crimes increase, not decrease as he has
shaken up the overall security situation not
funded or underfunded state level and local
level police officers in favor of the military
and things like that. So he hasn't fixed the
security problem or started to diminish the
violence and the real challenges that people
face day to day in their life.
O'NEIL: And he also came in riding this anti-corruption
crusade that he would stop the backroom deals
and the stealing that unfortunately did happen
in the Mexican government and throughout very
parts of society and the like, and unfortunately
that has not happened either. And there have
been some videos of his family members taking
bribes in various cases in cafeterias and
the like and wondering where that money goes.
So there's a feeling there that things really
haven't changed.
SIERRA: What is the Biden-AMLO relationship
like? Do they get along?
O'NEIL: Well, interestingly, Trump and AMLO
got along very well. I think for two reasons.
One is they have somewhat similar temperaments.
They are believe very strongly, very self-assured
in their own ability to do things, they see
themselves as messiahs or leaders in many
ways, but the other real reason is that Trump
didn't ask very much of AMLO. All he asked
is that he stopped migration to the border.
But all the other things AMLO was doing in
Mexico, the various economic changes or political
changes or AMLO's attacking of the press and
these things, Trump didn't care very much
about at all. In fact, didn't care about.
Even security issues, he really didn't press.
And so I think it was an easy relationship
for AMLO.
O'NEIL: So fast forward to Biden, the Biden
administration is much broader. You see them,
yes, of course they care about migration and
we see that as continuing, but they care about
security issues, they care about economic
issues, they care about labor issues, they
care about democratic checks and balances,
human rights, these sorts of things and that
interest of the United States and what's happening
inside Mexico in the domestic agenda I think
is quite uncomfortable for AMLO and he's let
that be known.
O'NEIL: So I think there is a real challenge
in Mexico today as he has a very strong agenda
where he wants to roll back energy reforms
and bring the energy sector back to the Mexican
government, the control of the Mexican government.
He wants to kick out foreign investors and
others that have been there, particularly
in this sector. He wants to limit the role
of political opposition and political opponents
and the like. So there has been already a
democratic backsliding within the country.
SIERRA: It s unclear where that democratic
backsliding is headed, but like so much else
with Mexico, it s worth keeping an eye on.
Because walls aside, what happens in Mexico
will continue to affect life in the United
States, every day.
O'NEIL: One of the most important reasons
to root for a stable Mexico is that they are
at our border. So if Mexico does well, the
United States will do well. If Mexico is doing
poorly, then it will be a huge problem for
the United States. And Mexico through the
last several decades has been with all of
its ups and downs, a pretty stable and safe
and good neighbor to the United States. We
have a neighbor that does not have terrorism,
we have a neighbor that has a quite stable
economy, we have a neighbor that, yes, has
sent us migrants, but those have enriched
very much our economy and many of them have
then headed back and gone back to Mexico.
And we have a neighbor who for the last 25
plus years has been a democracy.
O'NEIL: And I think all of those things, stability,
the shared values, and the economic ties that
have developed between the two countries have
made the United States safer, have made the
border more stable, and have actually made
the United States more competitive. So the
flip side of that is if you did not have a
democratic Mexico, if you did not have a stable
Mexico, if you saw organized crime and others
grow to the point where they controlled the
territory, those would pose huge problems
for the United States, both the cities along
the border and the states along the border,
but for the overall economy given how linked
we are economically, societally, culturally,
and the like.
SIERRA: This relationship has a direct impact
on the lives of millions of Americans. From
educational and cultural ties to our diplomatic
and economic endeavours, we are in it together.
Within all of our shared responsibilities
is a long history of partnership. And for
all our problems, the basic relationship is
a good one, and there would be an enormous
amount to lose if the relationship deteriorates,
and it s something we shouldn t take for granted.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes. Have a question
or some feedback? Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. Our intern
is Natalia Lopez. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode was provided
by Claire Felter and Diana Roy. Original music
is composed by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks
go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why
It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra signing
off. See you soon!